Hey, I'm Zach.
I'm Keith.
I'm Ned.
And I'm Eugene.
Zach: And we are The Try Guys.
Eugene: And we are The Try Guys.
Ned: And we're gonna tell you
how to become a YouTube star.
Here we go!
Woo!
[Narrator] Here's how
to be a YouTube star,
featuring The Try Guys.
Keith: Could you turn Ned down?
Zach: Yeah.
Keith: Is that something
you can do?
[Narrator] The Try Guys
are huge YouTube stars.
They have a massive fan base,
and millions of people watch
the four personalities,
well, try anything.
First, they'll tell us why
their online formula works.
Keith: Why do people like
to watch other people try?
Ned: I think you get to feel what we feel
even though you are not
trying, you're watching.
Zach: The core idea of trying things,
which is where we started from,
is just this idea of exploring
things that are familiar
to other people's passions and identities.
So I think on that base
level there's an excitement,
if we are trying something
that you are familiar with,
we're either going to learn
something that you care about
or experience a struggle that you know
that you haven't been able to communicate
to the world at large.
But then I think there's
also just a general interest
and excitement of four
guys who are willing
to go into things with an open mind
and see what the world has to offer.
[Narrator] So what's a
YouTube personality anyways?
Ned: I literally have no idea.
Keith: There are many types
of YouTube personalities.
But probably the best are the ones that
talk straight to camera,
talk about their life,
have a huge social meltdown,
and then apologize for it.
Ned: Yeah.
Keith: That's a really big thing.
Eugene: That's correct.
Ned: This may be the hardest
video I ever have to make.
I'm just...
I'm so sorry.
Keith: We found out that
our merch that we released
causes people to projectile vomit.
Ned: Excuse me while I sip some...
Zach: Oh he's sipping some...
Keith: He's sipping tea.
Ned: Sipping tea! There it is.
Zach: OK, there are a couple
YouTube archetypes, right?
You've got the cutie,
who's just, like, innocent, bubbly, fun.
"Hey guys! What's going on?"
You've got the prankster,
you know, the old jokester.
The guy that just likes
to mess with his friends.
There are the gurus, people
that you turn to for advice,
the ones who feel like they
got it figured all out,
Keith.
Keith: Then you have hot twins.
Zach: Hot twins.
Keith: We only have a
half of our...
Your twin couldn't make it.
Ned: Oh, what if you had a twin?
You'd be so much more famous.
Well, you'd have to divide by two though.
Zach: Probably our favorite
subgenre of YouTube
is the hot-twin subgenre.
There are so many, just,
attractive twin couplets.
And I don't understand
where they all come from
and how they all figure out
that, just, YouTube is where they belong.
Ned: We were in a museum, actually,
and the category of the exhibit
was audience surrogates.
Zach: Oh, like, literally
us were in the museum.
Ned: Yeah, The Try Guys were in a museum,
not we were walking in
a museum the other day.
Keith: That's what I
thought you were saying.
Eugene: You know, I like to go to museums
by myself sometimes.
Zach: Yeah!
Eugene: Do you guys do that?
Ned: Yeah.
Keith: No.
Ned: Well, I used to.
Eugene: But a few children
stopped me at the Natural History Museum.
Zach: Ah, so good, a lot of
their bones.
Eugene: I was looking at
the bones, and they said, "What
are you doing by yourself?"
Zach: One of the best collections
of bones in the world.
Eugene: I didn't know what to say,
and I said, "It's OK
to be alone sometimes."
And that sounded so cryptic.
And...but you know what? It's
OK to be alone sometimes.
Ned: See? That's how you
become a YouTube star:
authenticity.
Which is why I wanna tell you
about The Try Guys' new merch.
Zach: That is, to be a YouTuber,
you have to be able to
plug at the drop of a hat.
[Narrator] Vulnerability.
What is it, and why is it important?
Keith: The reason we are
vulnerable in our videos
is because it is OK to
be vulnerable in life.
And I think we wanna demonstrate that
that kind of thing is good. It's healthy.
And it allows you to be
closer to one another
when you're vulnerable around one another.
It just helps destigmatize this idea
of showing your emotions.
Ned: I think it stands in stark
contrast to what is, like,
a typical view of masculinity
where you're supposed to be
stoic and not show any emotions.
Oftentimes tackle, like, very
difficult personal subjects
and process it by talking
about it on YouTube.
Woo!
Zach: Being vulnerable I think allows you
to take the mask off
and present what is hopefully
a truer version of yourself.
It allows you to be raw.
It allows you to be in that place,
and that place of vulnerability
is where you can make mistakes,
where you can admit to failures,
and that's where growth can occur.
Eugene: It's kind of hard, because
everything is voyeuristic now,
and everything is, like, in your face.
Social media has sort of
distorted what we think is real.
So sometimes it's really
hard to even interpret
or understand if someone is
being completely themselves.
If you are giving 100% of
yourself in that moment,
then people can smell it.
Especially the younger
generation. They know.
'Cause I think we're
constantly bombarded now
by ideas of authenticity
when really it's just
sometimes to sell something.
It's not just branding of authenticity,
it's actually being authentic,
and I think that's good
for young kids to remember
when they're starting to film themselves,
just because that's a
difficult thing to do
when you're really young.
[Narrator] What about oversharing?
How much of your life
should you keep to yourself?
Zach: I think the four
of us have struggled with
what amount of our full selves
we should put out online.
Like, I kept that fact
that I had a girlfriend
secret from the internet for two years,
just because I wanted to
have that corner of my life
where I was, you know, growing
and experiencing something
organically, without it being
seen under the microscope
of what, like, people thought about her
and having to subject her to that.
On one hand, we have
this amazing opportunity
to share our lives and to affect people
and to show our vulnerabilities
and things that we struggle with
that maybe you're struggling with too.
But also, you wanna
have a part of your life
that is private and separate,
especially when it comes to
relationships and family.
Keith: But it's tougher when, you know,
you're famous for being you.
I mean, for the most part,
like, if you meet me in public,
I'm pretty much the same
person you see on a video.
Like, I'm me,
for the most part.
Zach: I'm a little dumber
on camera, but not much.
Keith: Yeah he's a little
dumber on camera.
Ned: I'm a lot dumber
on camera.
Keith: That's for sure.
But you'll have to find out for yourself.
Zach: When you become digitally famous.
Eugene: Other people should
not own your contents.
They can own your content,
but they can't own the
content of your character.
Zach: Everyone get a box.
Eugene: An actual physical box.
Ned: Write down all your secrets.
Take out two.
Zach: Then bury the box.
Make a treasure map.
Give it to future generations.
They're gonna have the time of their life.
Oh my God, if you discovered
a treasure map right now,
we would all drop
everything and go, right?
Keith: Right? I wish.
Zach: Oh my God.
[Narrator] Now it's time
to put it all together.
We had Ned, Eugene, Keith, and Zach
demonstrate the Try Guys method of success
with two inventions:
the spider catcher, and the fruit peeler.
Ned: It's pink. It's got brushes.
Zach: This is called the Critter Catcher.
Ned: My Critter Catcher.
Zach: Nice. Nailed it.
Eugene: And this is the critter.
Keith: That's the critter.
Zach: So the idea...can
I see what the gun does?
Ned: Can I be the critter?
Zach: Wait, open it up. Oh!
Ned: Ow! I've been caught!
Keith: Oh wow.
Zach: I like...can you
do that right to camera?
It looks like an alien's face.
Keith: This is awesome. Look at this.
It seems like an old cartoon
that would just say "BAM!"
Bam!
Zach: I don't even want it
for bugs. I just wanna play with it.
Keith: I'm not a murderer!
I'll use my plastic tentacles!
Zach: Hey, it works!
That's cool.
Keith: Wow, look at him.
He's in there.
Ned: Pretty almost.
Keith: But if he was wriggling, I think
he could get out of this.
Ned: Yeah.
Eugene: Wait, do you
guys actually kill bugs
when you see one? I can't kill.
Zach: What kind of bugs?
Eugene: Any bugs.
Zach: Well you can't kill cockroaches
because then other cockroaches
smell it, and they come.
Ned: Flying cockroach in the wild.
Zach: Grr, I'm mad!
Keith: I have a lot of forward thrust.
So yeah, that time I
didn't thrust hard enough.
All: Ayy!
Zach: Oh no!
Ned: All right, what's next?
Zach: This is the Orange
Peel Professional.
Not to be confused with
the Orange Peel Amateur.
Ned: Oh boy.
Zach: Wow.
This is gonna get juice everywhere, right?
Ned: Put it on the carousel.
Eugene: Yeah, stab that down.
Ned: Poke it in the top.
Eugene: Put it right on the
top, so lean it in, lean it in
a bit. There we go. Yes!
Zach: Oh, through that.
Eugene: Always do it in
the hole.
Keith: Oh, don't go
through the, the thing!
Ned: Sometimes you gotta push hard.
Zach: There are two buttons.
There's a one and a two.
Ned: Let's go two.
Keith: Let's ramp it up to two.
Zach: Oh God!
All: Whoa!
Zach: Oh, but it didn't...
[Producer] You had it started from the...
Zach: Oh, Ned!
Keith: Oh!
Ned: I think that's my fault.
Keith: If it was really a
professional, it would've
known where it was starting.
Zach: Maybe one will go backwards?
That is very satisfying.
Keith: When you keep
going will it take off...
Oh! It's taking off the white part now!
Oh!
Eugene: Oh!
Ned: Oh, it's just going
back and forth.
Keith: Let's keep running it!
Yeah baby!
Ned: Keep this orange string going!
Yeah!
Keith: Oh, she looks good!
Yes baby!
Ned: Orange juice!
Keith: Oh! You look good, girl!
Ned: Oh, you're looking like a snack!
Keith: Yes!
You are skinny!
Zach: Uh oh, uh oh,
I'm gonna need a paper
towel, I'm gonna need
a paper towel right now.
Ned: Slurp it! Slurp it, Zach!
Eugene: Drink it! Drink it!
All: Aww.
Ned: Be sure to get your copy
of (mumbling) (bleep) today!
Let's go!
Ned: Oh, I chewed if for too long.
Zach: Mine fell apart in my mouth.
Keith: Eugene!
And that's how to become
famous on YouTubes.
Eugene: No, it's not.
Ned: It's one way.
Eugene: We're generally
very unproblematic,
so we really like to act like we are.
Zach: Until now...
Eugene: It's why we're having
a lot of fun right now.
Zach: which is why this video
is gonna be us becoming problematic.
Eugene: Or we could...
Ned: Yes, Keith, yes!
Eugene: Don't do it!
Ned: Join the dark side!
Join it!
Eugene: Oh Jesus.
Ned: Woo!